so I'd like to talk about an issue that
isn't discussed enough there have been
recently a number of stories of false
rape accusations and the terrible
consequences that accompany them and
before we get into the examples I think
the first question of course anyone asks
is is well how common it is this problem
I mean how often does it happen that
somebody is falsely accused of rape
feminists and other liberals well if
you've heard them talk about this you've
probably heard the figure 2% and here's
the thing about feminist
feminists love to make up statistics I
think it's their favorite thing to do in
the world hey enjoy that even more than
yelling and screaming at men they they
they just love making up statistics it
is it's really that's their favorite
pastime so they have this 2% figure that
they will often cite they'll say well
two percent of all rape accusations are
false
now I want to give you an example of how
that that that argument is framed and
you know I was just looking this up
online to try to get to the bottom of it
and I found just for instance an article
on the website quartz calm which was
published in 2017 and it says this it
says let's start with the idea that
false rape accusations ruin lives and
are therefore a universal risk to men
generally feminists dismissed this idea
by arguing that false accusations are
rare only between 2% and 10% of all
reports are estimated to be false what's
equally important to know however is
that false rape accusations almost never
have serious consequences
now we'll get to that almost never have
serious consequences thing in a second
but looks look at 2% to 10% okay so um
that's the range that we've been given
here
and so 2% is you know like I said that's
that's what you'll most offered here
look looks look at that the problem with
2% is that as I said it's a made-up
figure okay it's not it's tit is not
it's just it's not based in reality a
report by a man named Edward Greer which
was published in the Loyola of Los
Angeles Law Review and I think 2000 or
2001 tried to get to the bottom of this
figure to find out where it originates
that's why it's a lengthy report where
he goes into detail about this idea that
only 2% of all fall of all rape
accusations are false and Greer
discovered that it originates from a
book written in 1975
and the book gives this figure and cites
as its source a speech which was given
by a judge the year before so greer
contacted the judges law clerk and found
out that nobody really knows or
remembers where that figure came from
it's just it's just something that the
guy said in speech in other words it's a
false statistic from 40 years ago so
when you hear somebody say that well
only 2 percent of rape accusations are
false
most likely here's how it goes okay this
is how they like to trace the how they
came about that um figure what it
probably means is that that person solid
on facebook from someone who saw it in
an article written by someone who read
another article written by someone who
got it from a book written by someone
who got it from a from a from a speech
given by a judge who doesn't remember
where he got it from okay that's that's
how that's how we come up with with
statistics in in modern America now
what about 10% because that was the
other that was the other figure that we
were given 10%
well I'm not really sure where 10% I'm
not sure where this 10% figure comes
from but in any case 10% is pretty high
isn't it like 10% of people who are
accused of rape are innocent
isn't that a really hot so if you've got
a thousand men in a room and they've all
been accused of rape 100 of them are
innocent that seems like a high figure
to me
the fact that the author of this article
apparently thinks is a negligible figure
is pretty frightening but here's the
other problem we have no idea how many
innocent men are are really accused of
rape because the only way that we can
begin to quantify that number is by
looking at the men who have been
completely vindicated of the charges and
so they're the only ones that we can
even start to quantify and it's
impossible to even quantify them but
that's to assume that every man falsely
accused of rape has been vindicated
which of course is not the case it
stands to reason that there's a certain
number of men who are in prison right
now for rape and who didn't do it and
who are on sex offender registries yet
did not commit the crime how many of
them are we have no idea we have no clue
but we do know that false accusations
happen how often do they happen we don't
know exactly we know they happen and we
do know also that it's very easy to ruin
a man's life and go to get him put in
prison based on a false accusation
so that's really what makes the false
accusation things so scary is that it's
it's really easy to do all it takes is
um is someone who's willing to tell a
lie and tell it halfway convincingly and
stick to the lie and if they're willing
to do that
they can probably get you put in prison
even without any other evidence
that's what's terrifying about it now so
let's give some examples exhibit a a man
was a story in the daily wire yesterday
about a man who was released from prison
from a fifty year prison sentence
because it turned out that the person
who accused him of sexual abuse lied
under oath
now the accuser is is a minor we don't
know her exact age at least I looked it
up I you know it's apparently we don't
know what her age is exactly so not sure
about that but the accuser said that the
guy's name is Joshua Horner he said
Joshua Horner molested her and then shot
her dog in order to intimidate her in
the silence that's the story to the
story she told is that he molested her
and then said and then I believe it was
something like he said you know if you
tell anyone I'm gonna kill you and then
in order to demonstrate his seriousness
he's shot and killed the dog he was then
convicted by a non-unanimous jury not
really sure how that happens and
sentenced to 50 years in prison now
several months actually about a year and
a half into his sentence it was
discovered that the dog he supposedly
killed was still alive and well okay had
never never been killed never been shot
now um how is it that the police and the
prosecutor never thought to check on
this key piece of evidence I don't know
I'm not sure how that happens the girl
said that the man raped her and shot her
dog well it seems like if you could find
a dead dog with a bullet hole in its end
then that's a pretty good accusation and
pretty good indication that the
accusation is true right but if you
can't find the dog then that's a pretty
good that's a pretty relevant evidence
on the other side of the equation
but yet nobody checked at all how is
that possible so this guy is - what
makes it scary
this guy was sent to prison for 50 years
based only on the word of this girl no
other evidence and even the other
evidence that could have been used to
either vindicate him or or indicate his
guilt was never even nobody ever even
thought to check on it until he'd
already been in prison for a year and a
half so it turns out that the accuser
had lied about that detail at least and
when the investigators came to ask her
about all of this she fled she ran away
so Horner was eventually released from
prison though the DA has said that he
doesn't know he can't say for sure that
Horner is actually innocent of
molestation but there isn't any evidence
to maintain a conviction and there is
now very good evidence that the accuser
is a liar so he's out now
let's just imagine so we really don't
know if the whole story is false or not
but let's just imagine for a minute that
Horner is actually entirely innocent of
the whole thing and it seems very
possible that he isn't see it seems even
likely that that he is completely
innocent because there would be no
reason there'd be simply no reason for a
for a legitimate rape victim to concoct
some bizarre story about her dog getting
shot like there's no reason to embellish
to that extent if you actually were a
victim of this horrible crime um
but here's the problem Horner's life and
his reputation are now going to be
forever stained forever ruined because
of this accusation even if it is untrue
so not only does he have to deal with
the trauma of spending a year and a half
in prison as a supposedly a piston as a
rapist is not a fun experience and it
seems also there's a pretty high
likelihood that he was a victim of
sexual abuse in prison because that's
what they do to rapists in prison not
only does he have to deal with that but
now he also has a lifetime of suspicion
that will never go away there are other
examples recent examples
there were and these are just from the
last few months two men were falsely
accused of rape by a Sacred Heart
University college student both men had
to leave school and one lost his
football scholarship over it and then it
turned out that the girl made up the
story because I think she felt guilty
after having consensual sex with them
she was worried that her boyfriend will
find out or something and so so she
ruined their lives you know
because that's what you do in another
case there was a man expelled from
school and subjected the public
humiliation by a woman who accused him
of raping her a frat party the the
accuser the accuser says that she was
drugged
and assaulted but an investigation
including a medical exam and rape kit
found absolutely no evidence that any
form of sexual contact took place
consensual or otherwise so the DA you
know came out and he said very plainly
he said her allegations are quote simply
not accurate um then there were men two
men who were released from prison a few
months ago after serving 26 years for a
supposed gang rape that never occurred
the accuser now admits that she invented
the story in another recent case again
these are all just for the last few
months a woman claimed that two men had
kidnapped and raped her at gunpoint and
then she later admitted that the claims
were alive when police found video
evidence that contradicted her tale and
again these are just four Alaskan months
notice a couple of things
about these cases
notice how in every case it was just one
small thing that rescued these guys and
in some cases rescued them after they'd
already been in prison for a while but
without that thing they'd all still be
in prison so in one case the accuser had
sent sexually explicit text messages to
her alleged rapist clearly indicating
that she didn't think she had been raped
after it actually happened in another
your video surveillance another there's
a dog that they happened to find in
another there's there's the small detail
of the fact that the guy didn't actually
have sex with the woman if he had had
sex with her even consensually then he'd
be doomed notice something else in every
case
the penalties for the false accusers or
potential false accusers range from mild
to non-existent so the one the woman who
made up the gunpoint rape was charged
with a misdemeanor the woman who
invented the frat party rape will face a
lawsuit but as far as I know no legal
penalties the woman who put two men in
prison for 26 years will not be
prosecuted at all because of statute of
limitations the Sacred Heart University
of students who ruined the lives of two
to two men make him the story she's
gonna go to jail for 12 months she got
the harshest penalty and as for Joshua
Horner's accuser if she did indeed make
up the abuse like she made up the dead
dog there's no indication that she'll be
charged with any crime at all we also
don't know her age so she could be very
young I mean we don't know and we also
don't know what role the adults in her
life may or may not have played in
helping her to cover up the lie about
the dog so
the thing though that ties all these
cases together is that while the while
the accusers who all happen to be women
in these cases
while the women received either no
penalty or a very light penalty all of
the men the accused did receive or would
have received penalties that far
exceeded the punishments that the false
accusers faced
to me just seems like a gross injustice
you know rape is a monstrous crime
because of how it violates and
dehumanizes the victim and because of
the lifelong devastation that it causes
but falsely accusing somebody of rape
is a monstrous crime for the same reason
let's think about think about the ways
that a false accuser harms her victim
okay number one the years of false
imprisonment so that's pretty that's
pretty big deal number two he faces
serial sex abuse while he's in prison
because that's how rapists are treated
in prison number three his his
reputation is permanently ruined number
four his personal relationships probably
his marriage if he's married will likely
be destroyed number five he's got loss
of employment days never he's gonna lose
whatever job he had he's never gonna be
able to find a good job again most
likely number six there's the severe
emotional and psychological trauma and
then on and on right the dozens of other
consequences too numerous to list even
though that article I read at the top
said that rarely are there serious
consequences for false rap rape
accusations I would say that there are
always serious consequences it's just a
matter of how serious and how far does
it go and that really depends on how
quickly
um the man can demonstrate his own
innocence or if he can ever demonstrate
it at all
take some 26 years then he's gonna be in
prison for those 26 years right
a woman or a man who would subject
another human being to all of that
because again think about what for the
false rape accusation it's not just like
it's it's it's it's not a momentary
thing you are you are ruining their life
you are taking another human being and
obliterating everything about their life
you're blowing it to pieces
and someone who would do that is no
better than a rapist or murderer I
really make no distinction
I make no distinction between a woman
who would send a man to jail to prison
for a rape he didn't commit
I make no moral distinction between her
and a man who actually did commit a rape
I think morally they are the same
and not only is that false accuser not
only is she morally deranged but she is
a threat to society
just as the rapist is a threat to
society so is she because she possesses
the the not only the willingness to tell
the most damaging kinds of lies but she
passes possesses the ability to do so
convincingly and so she's a danger she's
a danger to any man who happens to end
up in a room alone with her she's a
danger to any man who she she develops a
grudge against she can destroy a man's
life with one lie
that's the way it works she doesn't need
any evidence she needs nothing but the
lie
and that will be enough at the very
little it may be enough to put him in
prison at the very least it'll be enough
to destroy his reputation destroy his
life the stories relationships could get
him fired from his job
get his scholarships taken away get him
kicked out of school at the very least
just the just the story that's it will
be enough to do that
um
so she's a danger to society
and the only way to protect her next
potential victim is to lock her in a
jail cell for a very long time
so it seems obvious to me that false
rape accusers at least those who are
adults you know children who make up
stories even though they also even
though that does happen like it maybe it
happened with Joshua Warner it does
happen and I mean
it is devastating for the person who
falls victim to that sort of thing you
know what kind of punishments should
should those kids face and that's sort
of a different subject but for the
adults it seems clear to me that they
ought to be given the same sentence that
would have gone to their victim
that's that seems clear
so we have you know
limitations and all that but if not for
that then the woman who put the those
men in jail for 26 years she should at a
minimum be in jail for 26 years
and then she should have to from there
serve out whatever the rest of their
sentence would have been now of course
look I'm not suggesting that any any
woman who accuses a man of rape should
automatically go to jail if the man is
found not guilty like I'm not saying
that because obviously just because a
rape isn't proved doesn't mean that it
was invented
just as there are men who are falsely
accused who are in prison right now for
rape there are plenty of men who have
committed rapes and are not in prison
because they were never caught or it
couldn't be proved in court or whatever
but if evidence is uncovered which
positively indicates a false accusation
then there should be an investigation
and a trial I mean in all these cases
there was evidence right there's the dog
there's the video sort of evidence text
messages you know whatever DNA like all
of these things can be positive evidence
to positively indicate that a false
accusation has occurred and if you have
that then there should be an
investigation there should be a trial
and if the woman is found guilty she
should go to jail for a very long time
now
you know rape can be very hard to prove
in a court of law of false accusations
can be hard to prove as well but both of
them can be proven and when they are it
seems obvious to me that they should be
treated exactly the same
I mean that's the only way that you're
gonna be able to protect men and women
too although I you know I think probably
women are falsely accused of rape lot
lot less frequently but that's the only
way to protect people from from from
these kinds of things
and it's very easy you know it's it's
feminists like to talk all the time
about how you know man or the how women
live in fear because of you know they
have to worry about walking you know in
a parking lot by themselves or walking
on the street because they have to worry
about men man or monstrous and all this
kind of stuff and I don't doubt that
those are concerns that women have to
have that's a terrible thing because
there are some there are really bad men
out there who have the physical ability
to dominate women and are willing to use
that ability to very evil ends
but on the other end of the spectrum you
know you can't completely dismiss this
very real fear that men have
that some evil woman could come along
and just ruin their life with a story
because that does happen and it can
happen it's a very real concern
feminists just dis they just laugh that
off like it doesn't happen it doesn't
matter but it does happen and it does
matter
and I think we have to treat it very
seriously when it does happen
I know there's always gonna be the
concern that well you know if you start
penalizing false accusers in this way
then aren't you making women who are
victims of rape aren't you making them
hesitant to come forward well you know I
kind of think that maybe the opposite is
true that in this environment now where
you know any story is immediately is
immediately believed and and you know
any you know a woman could ruin any
man's life just with a story you know in
this kind of environment where there are
false accusations and then you have all
these stories that come out of men who
are released after being falsely
imprisoned all that stuff I think I
think this environment serves to
unfairly discredit women who are
actually victims of rape
so if you can weed a lot of that stuff
out and start penalizing the real false
accusers but I think ultimately it'll
it'll do the opposite
and it will lend more credibility to the
to the you know actually true
accusations
so just some things to think about
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed